it is time for drew's news your good
news pat on the good news back and with
me at the desk is world's greatest
co-pilot bossy russ matthews hi
everybody hi guys
can we talk about can we talk about chef
sam
how do you feel for starters that was so
cute
i mean what did you think you saw
everything i saw everything what do i
think girl good for you that's what i
think hello
he's so cute and he's so accomplished
and so smart and i felt like there was a
real spark there so what's the deal are
you gonna see him again um we we texted
already um yes well i think it's very
brave of you to let us in this and now
we are all on the edge of our seats and
riveted but no pressure but we do want
to know okay well i'll i'll keep people
informed in a way that feels comfortable
for myself you know this is just life is
a one foot in front of the other and i
have stayed in the still position for a
very long time well i appreciate you at
least putting it in neutral and seeing
what happens
don't get into gear talk
okay
well let's shift gears right now
actually but keeping on dating here's a
fascinating story experts say there's a
brand new type of dating trend for the
new year uh hype at bay reports more
people are trying out something called
dry dating bumble reports 54 of daters
say they're being more mindful about
dating and for some this means sharing
coffee instead of a cocktail dry so no
alcohol nationwide the average number of
people who are drinking has dropped by
five percent since 2019 which seems
impossible during the pandemic that less
people are drinking i think if five
percent of the population are drinking
less than the the people who are
drinking are drinking 100 times more
than they used to drink but what about
dating without drinking because i i
don't i think there's two types of
dating the people who are just looking
to hook up and have fun you should mix
some vodka into that but if you're
looking uh for like interviewing people
for a potential partner i think you
should just go out and get a cup of
coffee at first i'm now dry dating
it's not it's hard
it's not
people could probably use a drink or two
right i've never been on a dry day in my
entire life all right next up new year
new you it's the start of 2022. what new
habits do you want to create in your
life well buzzfeed reports that reese
witherspoon shared her 2022 tips and she
got a great response from none other
than bina garten that's right on reese's
list was a big glass of water every day
10 minutes of daylight in the morning an
hour of reading and an early bedtime at
10 with no late night tv to that ina
responded with her list more large
cosmos more late nights
more staying in bed to play sudoku in
the morning and finally lots of time
with the people you love oh so
of course i had to get on the phone and
text reese witherspoon and see if i
could get a little tidbit from her and
guess what everybody hot off the press
what she responded oh my gosh hi
yeah i love this
just now okay
rhys says ina garten is the queen of all
things listen to her not me with a cute
emoji
i love that
so cute
you know i gotta say i think uh reese's
and aina's list should have a baby
and i want to follow that list yeah a
little bit of both right yeah that's
smart i mean i can't think of two
greater women to follow than reece aina
i love that you can just text me through
the spoon too could we send her a little
message
does everyone want to send a message
this is in real time you guys it's
really happening this is really
happening okay hi um everybody has a
quick message for you one two three hi
brees hi
we all love you so much and we love your
words of wisdom thank you although we
want to follow you into everything that
you do mwah happy day
bye
thanks guys that was so fun so cute now
rossi thoughts do you have any uh new
year's resolutions
i took the liberty of making a list do
you want to hear him i would love it
okay well i was going to say stop
watching 90 day fiance but that's just
not going to happen so i said stop
following my favorite people on 90 day
fiance on instagram because i'm getting
a little too close to the sun so i'm
going to do that
um stop obsessing over what i want
carrie bradshaw to do and just enjoy and
just like that i'm going to do that i
need that one
what about um continue with my daily
moisturizing routine because as you can
tell it's really working and then
finally get married to the love of my
life this year is the year it's gonna
happen
that's all i want that's all i need for
20.2
so the writers and i on the show came up
with a list of our own in honor of reese
and aina okay number one don't take your
phone into the bathroom oh no really
everybody does it don't if you say you
don't you're a liar i totally do all
right pet at least four cats a day oh
that's cute
um i have two cats so i'll double pet uh
attempt to not cyberstalk your ex
that's a good one do you do that i've
never done that okay our other is stock
up on dry shampoo daily and one scream
into the void you're gonna do that daily
this might save you
[Music]